maçons peintres ou canalisateurs ici
tous les corps de métiers du bâtiment
sont réunis au coeur de la zone
d'activité de trappes elancourt le
centre de formation des métiers du btp
accueille chaque année environ 200
apprentis et stagiaires
parmi eux boubacar élèves depuis deux
ans on a pris beaucoup d cgc on nous
apprend d'un projet a fait la pente
haussier de court des technologies et
beaucoup dé jà respecter aussi
les jeunes sont acteurs qui dessinent et
mettre en place le chantier après avoir
eu des notions en technologie et en
lecture de plans on leur apprend
justement cette autonomie ça va
permettre aussi aux jeunes d'avoir un
peu plus confiance en lui et présenter
ses idées car sur un chantier
tout le monde a droit de s'exprimer des
connaissances mise en pratique en
entreprise durant leur formation les
élèves sont en alternance
l'établissement organise des journées
portes ouvertes pour faire découvrir son
offre et ses métiers souvent méconnus
mais nécessaire la main d'oeuvre vient
souvent a manqué malheureusement il ya
très peu de jeunes
qu'ils viennent dans le métier dans les
métiers du bâtiment on pense à des
métiers qui sont pas forcément dans
lesquels on travaille dans des
conditions qui sont pas forcément
plaisante et pourtant on a besoin
aujourd'hui professionnel l'année
dernière il y avait fait un titre
façadier après j'ai demandé de faire un
aussi appelé par repris
ils m'ont accepté depuis que stp tu
voulais faire la peinture le centre
espère recruter une cinquantaine de
jeunes pour compléter ses effectifs
il est à découvrir jusqu'au vendredi 20
octobre